so we're asked to solve for X and we
have this equation with absolute values
in it so it's 4 times the absolute value
of x plus 10 plus 4 is equal to 6 times
the absolute value 6 times the absolute
value of x plus 10 plus 10 and at first
this looks really daunting but the key
is to just solve for this absolute value
expression and then go from there let me
just rewrite it so the absolute value
expression really jumps out so this is 4
times the absolute value of x plus 10
plus 4 plus 4 is equal to 6 times the
absolute value of x plus 10 plus 10 plus
10 so let's get all of the let's get all
of the absolute values of x plus 10 on
the left hand side so I want to get rid
of the 6 times the absolute value of x
plus 10 on the right well how would I do
that well I could subtract 6 times the
absolute value of x plus 10 from the
right but we've already seen this
multiple times if these two things are
equal and if I want to keep them equal
if I subtract 6 from the right hand side
I've got to subtract or if I subtract 6
times the absolute value of x plus 10
from the right hand side I have to
subtract the same thing from the left
hand side so we're going to have minus 6
times the absolute value of x plus 10
and likewise I want to get all my
constant terms I want to get this 4 out
of the left hand side so let me subtract
4 from the left and then I have to also
do it on the right otherwise my equality
wouldn't hold and now let's see what we
end up with what we end up with so on
the left hand side the 4 minus 4 that's
0 you have 4 of something minus 6 of
something that means you're going to end
up with negative 2 of that something
negative 2 of the absolute value of x
plus 10
remember this might seem a little
confusing but remember if you had 4
times if you had 4 apples and you
subtract 6 apples you now have negative
2 apples I guess you owe someone the
apples same way you have 4 of this
expression you take away 6 of this
expression you now have negative 2 of
this expression on the right a little
bit neater so it's negative 2 times the
absolute
value of x plus 10 is equal to well the
whole point of this of the of the 6
times X the absolute value of x plus 10
and minus 6 times the absolute value of
x plus 10 is to make those cancel out
and then you have 10 minus 4 which is
equal to 6 now we want to solve for the
absolute value of x plus 10 so let's get
rid of this negative 2 and we can do
that by dividing both sides by negative
2 you might realize everything we've
done so far is just treating this red
expression as almost just like a
variable and we're going to solve for
that red expression and then take it
from there so negative 2 divided by
negative 2 is 1 6 divided by negative 2
is negative 3 so we get the absolute
value of x plus 10 is equal to is equal
to negative 3 now this gets us to a very
interesting situation you might jump to
hey maybe this could be the positive
version of the negative but remember
absolute value absolute value is always
is always non-negative it could when you
take took the absolute value of 0 you
would get 0 but the absolute value of
anything else is going to be positive so
this thing right over here is definitely
going to be greater than or equal to 0
it doesn't matter what X you put in
there when you take its absolute value
you're going to get a value that's
greater than or equal to 0 so there's no
X that you could find that somehow going
to that let you put it there you add 10
you take the absolute value of it you're
actually getting a negative value so
this right over here has absolutely no
no solution and I'll put some
exclamation marks there for emphasis